- I'm sweating and it's
not even that hot in here,
I just think I'm so nervous.
(laughs)
- Hi, I'm Paris Kennedy.
- I'm Danny Wylde, and I am a porn star.
- My name's Zack, and I'm
definitely not a porn star.
- I'm about to watch some
porn with Allie Haze,
that she stars in.
- I'm a straight guy, and I'm
about to watch some gay porn.
- I don't really watch
straight porn that often.
- I don't know if this is
the point where I admit
that like I feel like I've
almost definitely seen a porn
with you in it before.
- My expectations are pretty high.
- This is a really old scene.
- Oh, excuses, here come excuses.
(both laugh)
- I do act quite a bit in this.
- It's broken down as Intro,
Blow Job, Sex 1, Sex 2.
- I also just noticed, this is one take,
that's insane, that's like Birdman.
- No kissing?
You just going for it girl.
- Just go for it.
- I'm sorry, I just keep getting
distracted by this frame,
it's just kind of like flesh.
- We went from just nice
kissing to there's a pee-pee.
- I think it's awesome that
porn stars say pee-pee.
- Little spank.
- It's getting good.
- Do they direct you to do the spank
or was that just like, "nah,
I'm in it, I'm feeling it."?
- It was in the script.
- Weiner's out you guys.
- Do you like it when they talk to you?
- Yeah, I do.
- Like, "hey baby."
You're like really good at sucking dick.
- Thank you, oh my god, that means a lot.
- I'm impressed.
- Oh, there's three guys here.
- Yes.
- There's so many just like, appendages.
- That's a really big penis.
- This is amazing, all you guys have beautiful penises.
- Thank you.
- How much time do you guys sit before
and like draw this out
like a football play?
- It's up to the camera guy really.
- Your abs must be killer.
Like your core strength, holy shit.
You're in the gym just like, "yeah".
- That's a typical one.
- Look at how much you're
sweating, holy crap.
- The roller skates are making me taller,
so he has to be on his tippy toes.
- Are you being spit-roasted?
- I don't have a dick in my butt.
- Are most porn stars like circumcised
or not circumcised, is that?
- I'm actually not circumcised.
- I could tell, I did.
That is something I was
able to tell very quickly.
- Oh wow, oh my god!
(laughs)
We are really going for it right now.
- How well do you know these, these guys?
- I just met them.
- That's seems very professional.
- Oh, that I just met them and-
- And you just dive right in.
- Yeah, totally.
- I would be nervous if I had
to do like a kissing scene.
- Girl, does that not hurt?
- It doesn't take a
toll on you physically?
- I know my body well
enough that when I'm ready
to be done, I'm like, "time-out."
- You do this, (clapping)
and I'll just (wet slapping)
that's basically what's
happening in our ears right now.
And then like some moans.
- Do you have to like do
that to your coochy-cat?
- No, it's kinda just for
the visual, for the viewer.
- Like are you enjoying this?
- Let's freeze on this
closeup of your testicles.
This is almost like abstract art.
I could see that like hung up
in some old persons apartment
and they don't even know what it is.
- It's not my, my style.
But I appreciate it.
(laughs)
I get it.
I'm pretty familiar with all the equipment
that you guys are working with.
- You know he's about to cum,
- (laughs) It's true.
- Cause they do a little fade.
- It's totally true.
- It'll show it like five
times, like in slow motion.
- Okay.
- He's gonna cum on the roller skates.
- He's cumming (laughs)
- Oh, wow.
- All right, well that was a thing we did.
- I think it's really
interesting, like to hear like,
how these actually get put together.
- You know it's not as awkward
as I thought it would be.
- He's a normal guy, he's just a dude.
- I commend you for actually sitting here,
and doing that, cause I
couldn't sit next to somebody
and be like, "watch me have sex."
(laughs)
I would be worried they'd
be like, "you like it like
that, that's what you do?"
- I'm not gonna lie, I
have a little like softie.
- Oh wow.
That's like such a big
compliment from a gay guy,
like I wanna cry right now.
- I'm glad my first time
watching was with you.
- Thank you, it was special for me, too.
- I could show you some of my videos,
but I think they're not as exciting.
- I think that's only fair, right?
- But I do get naked in a bunch of them.
- Sure, you got a nice
little bulge in there.
- Yo, porn start respects
my bulge, I'm in to that.